as a visual effects artist when I'm
watching movies I can't help but get
distracted analyzing all the awesome and
sometimes not so awesome visual effects
on screen when I'm watching sports
however that part of my brain is turned
off until recently when I was watching a
basketball game minding my own business
and saw this a percentage tracker that
tells you a player's probability to make
a shot from that specific spot on the
floor in real time which don't get me
wrong is super cool but I missed the
whole first half just staring at it but
after that game I started noticing just
how many effects are actually happening
during a Sports Broadcast and there's a
lot and whereas Hollywood films have
months if not years to execute effects
these visualizations are being generated
largely in real time this sent me down a
big old rabbit hole and I was shocked to
find that the tech behind visual effects
in live sports is just as fascinating
and intricate as the stuff that we see
coming out of Hollywood but while visual
effects in film have been around since
well nearly the Advent of the camera
itself visual effects in sports emerged
not that long
[Music]
ago imagine it's the year
1993 I will Faithfully execute the
office of President your surfing channel
is looking for a game to watch and you
land on a shot of a green field with
some white lines on it there's guys in
different colored uniforms and you hear
two old men just rambling didn't you
coach Bert Reynolds yes I did was he any
good but other than that you have no
information it's difficult to keep up
with the flow of the game when Vital
Information like what's the score and
how much time is left is not on the
screen so it's easy to see how
groundbreaking the introduction of the
score buug was in 1994 you can look up
there always know what the score is
while a digital scoreboard may seem
somewhat trivial it was actually a giant
hurdle at the time to get the graphic on
the screen the first problem was that
each Stadium had its own archaic
scoreboard with different ports cables
and electronics and for a while
broadcast teams had to man ually solder
and rewire Parts in order to get the
score interfaces working with their
Graphics interface that's getting the
data but processing that data in the
mid99s was a whole other Adventure the
live feed of the scoreboard had to run
to a group of broadcast trucks the
graphic overlay system which at the time
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars
would take the scoreboard data and
render a rudimentary graphic that
graphic consists of two video streams
the fill which contains the actual
graphic and the all important key which
contains the transparency map that
indicates which pixels the graphic
should affect these two streams are then
input into the linear key or another
piece of video equipment that actually
overlays the graphic on the broadcast
video all that work for this now funnily
enough after first seeing it many
Network Executives actually feared the
score buug would discourage viewers from
watching the idea being you tune in you
find out the Steelers are losing by 51
and decide I'm not watching this so you
turn it off before you get invested but
viewers love the score buug and so
networks eventually adopted it
universally other sports quickly adopted
their own version of the score buug and
so began a whole new level of Engagement
with broadcast sports as well as of arms
race over who could deliver the most
compelling and immediate visual context
to fans with football being the biggest
sport in the US the NFL continued to
innovate 1998 saw the introduction of
perhaps the most beloved onscreen
graphic the digital first down line also
known as the yellow line you see rather
than a simple 2D graphic with some
numbers that beautiful yellow line is
much more elegant in how it conveys to
the viewer what the goal of the offense
is it is a literal storytelling device
this team has to reach this far in this
much time or else they lose possession
it made football immediately more
accessible to non-f football fans and
the way it works is genius stadiums are
equipped with three High game camp
cameras these produce the camera angle
we're most used to seeing in a football
game these cameras are connected to
computers that contain a 3D
representation of the field that was
captured earlier through laser scanning
now because these broadcast cameras pan
tilt and zoom to follow the action this
transformation data has to be captured
for every frame as well by updating
every frame the camera's view in
relation to the field matches between
the real world and the 3D representation
perfectly with all of this math in order
a yellow line can finally be drawn in 3D
perspective you think that's it no we're
only halfway there because the last
thing the viewer wants is a giant yellow
line drawn all over the players like a
baby John Madden scribbled on the TV get
out of here baby John the system was
designed to tuck the line under the
players while still keeping it on top of
the grass this is called color filtering
and it's done by a very specific
software that takes an average of all
the Hues of the green you want the line
to be able to show up on kind of like
green screen only unlike a green screen
these H values have to be monitored by a
technician throughout the entire game as
wether and lighting conditions
invariably change this combination of
Technologies created a final result that
was so seamless to new audiences that
many people thought that it was actually
chock that the stadium workers would
clean up and reset off camera it was
simultaneously invisible and essential a
few years later ESPN built on these
visual effects and introduced the kzone
to the MLB what a cool name the kzone
the kzone presents a simple box to
represent the batter's Strike Zone and
shows whether the pitch is a strike or a
bol simple right well it's never that
simple two cameras one above home plate
and one above first base are set up to
capture the path of the ball once it
leaves the pitcher's hand as the pitch
is thrown each camera captures over 60
ball positions per second which is fed
to a computer that basically calculates
the trajectory and the speed now we
aren't quite done from a third camera
perspective they specify the strength
Zone The Box the height is measured from
the bottom of the batter's knees to
their mid shoulder it's controlled by a
dude on a joystick who draws it for
every batter that comes up and this
camera looks for any intersection
between the translated position of the
ball and the boundaries of the strike
zone an intersection indicates a strike
now while the K zone is somewhat
controversial to fans like the first
downline it's still providing a simple
visual representation a of a critical
part of the game these advancements were
taking flat graphics and bringing them
into the game this completely changed
the viewing experience of some sports I
mean think about NASCAR what was once
blurry video of a bunch of cars driving
in a circle began to look like a
fast-paced car chase with all the
information you might need to make sense
of it right there on the screen through
the use of satellites inar sensors and
3D reconstructions of the Raceway
broadcasters were able to track Graphics
to to moving cars as well as provide
crazy in-depth information like gear
position rotations per minute speed fuel
consumption all the stuff you want to
know and plenty that you probably don't
and while these sensors have been hard
mounted in cars for a while now more
recently this kind of realtime tracking
has been brought to players in 2014 the
NFL introduced RFID or radio frequency
identification tracking for those of you
who like more words the way it works is
each player has two RFID tags one each
shoulder pad that sends out positional
data to the 24 Ultra wide band antennas
placed throughout the middle level of
the stadium lineman actually need an
extra tag on their back due to the fact
that they start the play so low to the
ground and not because they're so big
they're massive don't body shame the
ball the pylons and even the officials
get RFID tags too with 53 players on
each team and all the extra devices
being tracked that's over 300 devices
working in tandem to provide data such
as location speed distance traveled and
acceleration and that's being updated 10
times per second so imagine what is
being created in a modern NFL broadcast
you have all the players tracked in 3D
space which we can lay out on our 3D
representation of the field and now even
moving cameras like the sky cam use
real-time 3D tracking to keep the
Virtual Field in line with the real
field at all times this means more
complex Graphics can be placed on a
moving image like the blue line of
scrimmage timers countdowns and this
Insanity look at the Slime Monster oh
it's the abominal slime man but these
Graphics can also make use of those RFID
trackers to create overlays of live
statistics that are tagged to players
and 3D lines tracing routes of a
receiver and even the path of the
football and so at this point in sports
the cameras the field the balls and the
players are all almost perfectly
replicated in 3D in real time what could
possibly be crazier well volumetric
capture volumetric capture is a
technique where a subject is filmed by
an array of cameras from all angles to
generate realistic and interactive 3D
renderings it was first introduced in
golf where players were brought into a
studio to capture their swing in 3D
which was later used during broadcast
for an in-depth three-dimensional
breakdown now this application is cool
but took days to process and the
Brooklyn Nets ain't got time for that so
last year they introduced the nerse 110
highresolution Canon cameras were placed
around barlay Center to capture the game
that data was used to generate realistic
renderings of the players and
environments in a matter of seconds
allowing the viewer to direct a virtual
camera wherever they want on a CG Court
seeing angles that were never before
possible
[Music]
future but why stop at just capturing a
real game why not add your own skins
your own environment and fully customize
an entire game and broadc
well that's exactly what Disney did just
this past year during an NFL game
between the Falcons and the Jaguars the
entire football field and all the
players in this game were brought into
the virtual world in a Toy Story themed
environment you had colorful Trails
behind the ball and the players Slinky
as a first down line and even the
commentators as toys look at them
sitting there in their little motion
capture suits it's adorable it was a
culmination of all the technology we've
been discussing like a proportionally
accurate CG field RFID tracking of the
players and the icing on this cake a
machine learning algorithm trained on
human motion that Faithfully applied
animation to all the toy players all of
this was being piped into the unity game
engine in order to be rendered and
played back at only a 20 second delay
from the live game broadcast that's
pretty good considering they're
converting a real game into a literal
video game now growing up I always
believed that as graphical capabilities
grew Sports video games like NBA 2K FIFA
and Madden would look more and more like
real life but the inverse is proving to
be true we now have the capability to
take a real sports event and replicate
it almost perfectly in the computer
giving us the ability to visualize any
piece of information view the game from
any perspective or just make the whole
thing look like whatever we want
anything is possible but if anything is
possible that begs the question when do
you stop adding more you see sports
broadcasting is currently in the same
boat as Hollywood and as we've learned
this last year with some massive box
office bombs just because you can do
anything with visual effects doesn't
mean you should looking at you flash
what's he talking about in both
Athletics and film gimmicks and
spectacle only get you so far what
viewers really care about is the story
an athletes Journey their rivalries
their struggles and their triumphs
it's about the unspoken narratives
etched into each play the stories in
sport are what pull us in and keep us
watching it's what makes Sports
Universal and visual effects should
serve Above All Else as a tool to
connect us deeper to the heart of that
story and as we've seen the
technological innovations that have
stood the test of time have done just
that so the next time you turn on a game
or throw on a match take a moment to
appreciate all the visual storytelling
that is hiding in plain sight and heck
maybe even tip your cap to The Unsung
artists and Technical Wizards behind the
scenes who are pushing us forward and
making all of this possible researching
this topic was such a good time if you
guys have any other topics you'd like us
to take a technical Deep dive on let us
know in the comments down below but in
the meantime I got a fake game to
pretend to watch so get out of
here oh we should have scored that goal
a I'm gonna this is I'm going to bring
this into my home life I'm going to take
this out on my the people closest to me
Sports make me feel